hallo zu einem neuen blog statt und
lockt heute so viel geld einkaufen also
hat wird nicht zum einkaufen ich habe
meine notizen dabei was ich so brauche
für die ganzen beigebracht dass es heißt
zu kaufland und nicht nach kaufland denn
im ruhrpott sagen wir immer gerne nach
kaufland
mai also dadurch dass wir ja nur zu 210
also haben sie nicht sind wir sehr
flexibel planung angenehm kann
eigentlich jeden tag aufs neue
seit heute ist der plan freunde wir
gehen bei kauft einkaufen für unsere
videos via video-stream genau das ist ja
das verschwundene folgen wir videos
drehen aber dann doch ganz kurzfristig
um einen schicken jörg weiß was wir
gehen heute einkaufen für die ganzen
nächsten videos und danach gehen wir in
die neue wohnung und arbeiten da an der
wand weil es lohnt sich nicht erst den
vormittag über den morgen mit einkaufen
zurück zu verbringen und dann zu finden
weil es im winter einfach ab 17 uhr
schon dunkel wird und wir wollen gerne
mit tageslicht treten dann die videos
für euch angenehmer sind genau
und ganz ehrlich schule zieht eine hand
richtig hässlich aus
hier war früher immer trainieren also
früher als vor einem jahr
und statt zu trainieren essen wir jetzt
einfach nur noch tot und kuchen das ist
jetzt unser leben ganz nämlich
irgendwann nicht mehr geschafft und
haben uns einfach abgemeldet ja deswegen
bin ich zu dünn
wahrscheinlich glauben wollte mich finde
ich gut
also ich würde gern zweifel also das ist
ja gar nicht zwei bürger zum mitnehmen
das ist mein moment ja im moment nehme
ich dir meine karte gebe die du bist
auch wenn die karten beauftragt da immer
wenn wir irgendwo karten kriegen muss
ich darauf aufpassen wenn es soweit ist
muss ich das dann vorliegen wenn es
einen automaten stecken sie davon ich
weiß ich hab noch nie hatte ich eine
sehr kleine region darf herr der ringe
du bist der kondom der karten
ok ich locker wenn man als gollum
gezeichnet ja aber du bist aber viel
schöner sagen können du bist nicht du
hauptsache lag noch einen kassenbon am
tv aber dafür kommen
aber warten wir noch eins ndr gemacht
entweder richtig oder iphone will mich
apple apple das geschenk sein ja es war
halt nicht dein schicksal es war ja auch
nicht denn morgen
daher wird alles seine richtigkeit in
diesem universum heimlich nähe
ja richtig das ist gar nicht mal dran
ich gar nicht richtig
das riecht nach kann ich finde ich nicht
gut die ich immer wert gelegt habe und
haben sie auch toilettenpapier meine
krieg ist der wunsch da haben haben uns
geschworen wir zusammen kaufen würden
egal wie schlechtesten geht und bin
benutze jeden cent umdrehen kaufen uns
immer viel einiges toilettenpapier und
gekauft haben sie jetzt roller und
dreilagige kann man seine versprechen
oder die familie kann man eigentlich
erst mal angebot ist dann einfach lagern
und kaufen
das ist doch unsinn also ich weiß wie
viele von euch die kaufland stories
sehen möchten bzw der wende einkaufen
gehen dass wir euch mitnehmen aber
irgendwie dass man nicht so gut wir sind
geübter mit der instagram story das
heißt wenn ihr uns auf unserem volk dann
habt ihr auf jeden fall uns ein bisschen
verfolgen können wo wir jetzt einkaufen
waren der kameras noch nicht so ich
glaube da braucht noch ein bisschen über
rechts ab in einem streng bewachte zone
nächstes mal mit dieser kamera und mit
einem blog dass wir euch damit nehmen
übrigens richtig süß sie hat eine ganz
liebe zuschauerin eine fanpage erstellt
und jetzt schreibt sich jedes mich
gerade gesehen beste blog er war steht
hier um weiter so abonnieren nicht
vergessen ich finde das so so so lieb
dankeschön für deine mühe falls du dass
dies weiß es sehr zu schätzen
da war ich nicht im surfen unter dem
wassertropfen regentropfen von der decke
unglaublich
also ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich
geschockt sind mein gott wir reden über
das kiki mobiles kino liegt mir sehr am
herzen sind wir erster wagen war den wir
so gemeinsam hatten
es ist wirklich alles an diesen kirchen
mobil und ich fahren oder sonst runde
möglich und ungemütlich während sogar
mal gelesen er wendet den
bandscheibenvorfall
durch dieses auto zu überspringen ist ja
so nicht so genau werden wir eingezogen
wir haben uns extra auto kissen gekauft
und in extra beheizbaren sitzen
das ist kein blut sein dass man nicht
also gut getan auf jeden fall
ich liebe euch mal mit durch unseren
aktuellen allen tag der ändert sich ja
irgendwie ständig jetzt gerade haben wir
noch ein video gedreht wir haben es
jetzt zwölf uhr
das video haben wir gestern angefangen
zu drehen es muss so kühlen haben was zu
ende gedreht ist die therapie zu torte
und die aufgabenverteilung ist bei uns
auch ganz gleich wo ich mal ganz kurz um
es ist irgendwie nie ein tag wie der
andere
ihr wisst ja dann würde er jetzt
mittlerweile erfahren dass wir am online
shop arbeiten natürlich nebenbei noch
filmen und dann noch umziehen in die
andere wohnung jetzt sind wir gerade bei
mir zuhause ich wurde im haus meiner
eltern das wissen auch ganz viele ich
von zwei etagen über ihm ein reines
familienhaus unter mir meine tanten
onkels und darunter meine eltern mit
meiner schwester genauso wie haben sie
wohnt ordnung im haus seiner eltern
haben hier zehn jahre später
ja hallo also im letzten block haben
ganz viele fragen auf wie ist eure
aktuelle wohnsituation warum sie dann
erst 15 monate es ist eigentlich vier
uhr stündlich viele kennen uns ja auch
noch gar nicht was drin ist
wir wollten noch bei mama und papa
genauso wie ich es tue
also meine es ist ein reines
familienhaus hier ich wohne ich hier
oben und hab den segen dass ich ihn
eigene küche habe ohne die wir youtube
sowieso geschichte gewesen und die küche
zeigen wir nun extra video ich bin doch
erst in diesem blog noch nicht bereit
sich in eine küche sozusagen ihr seht
immer nur die hälfte aber meine
küchenzeile ist auf der flucht vor große
küche hunter wohnt auch im haus seiner
eltern hat im keller einer wohnung mit
seinem bruder
so haben wir schon mal aufgedeckt und
ich nehme euch jetzt mal so ein bisschen
mit durch unseren alltag ihr wisst ja
wir sind dabei unseren job zu plant
schon ganz lange das ganze jahr über
meine nachricht welche abgesehen drehe
ich euch jetzt einmal ganz kurz um also
heute hat der tag so gestartet haben sei
es gekommen der war so gegen 9 uhr 45
hier dann haben wir das video für die
therapie von brüchen bringen dann haben
wir die therapie so torte zu ende
gedreht genau da ist es schon
ich habe jetzt das set für die fotos
gemacht und hamza kommt jetzt mit seiner
kamera und macht die footballer diese
torte real life die hat zwei nicht so
schöne seiten die es nicht schön
die ist schön dies ist dadurch die
wahrheit eine schöne sowie hat wirklich
zwei schöne und zwar nicht so schöne
seiten aber hamza darf endlich den
kuchen bzw die torte essen
zunächst beschäftigte was ist das okay
man denkt es doch nicht aufgibt dann
bitte so und meine aufgabe bzw unsere
aufgabe wird sein dass die aus angst uhr
um 70 auf vordermann bringen natürlich
nicht trainieren darf und ich sage dir
machen schätzung aber nur ein punkt
vorbeikommen einig schnack schnuck wir
nutzen jetzt ganz kurz die zeit am
mittag so ein bisschen spazieren zu
gehen
gottseidank also ich hab wirklich das
glück da wo ich jetzt wohne ist ein park
direkt am straßen ende und er kann also
das so von vorteil man kann joggen man
keinen spazieren einfach mal frische
luft schnappen richtig richtig tollen
das nutze ich auch noch solange ich hier
oder genau das machen wir ganz auf das
so ein bisschen spazieren gehen einfach
mal um und die beine zu vertreten auch
wenn das so ein bisschen über schweiger
kommt weil langweiliger kommt aber es
ist aber versuchen geht einfach mal viel
öfter raus an die luft das zugleich
total gut und in diesem park haben wir
auch den clip zum kinde regel zum xxl
der regel gedreht und der parcours
vorher war voll die leute haben gesagt
was machen die bekloppten
warum warum schaukelte jetzt im kinder
regeln warum geht der rutschen mit einem
kegel verlinke euch das video mal in die
infoboxen könnt ihr euch nochmal genauer
angucken und das ist der louis mein
kater louis hast du hunger
willst du total
willst du mit mir als ich mal fragt wo
der kuchen land berlin kuchen ist hälfte
unten bei meiner familie und hälfte hier
geht s zu haben nach hause gehen
das zweite ass also zwei stück habe ich
ja ach so intakt
bei uns heute doch ziemlich anders als
geplant aber wenn ihr euch dafür warum
auch noch mit übrigens willkommen zu
einem neuen tag
okay wir haben tatsächlich unserer neuen
wohnung zwei kleiderschränke
das erkläre ich aber gleich so in der
wohnung angekommen mein papa kommt
gleich nach und wenn wir den schrank
aufbauen der schritt ist riesig und zwar
werde ich den schrank im büro platzieren
das ist ein champ schrank ich muss hier
den gruppensieg es ist ein
kleiderschrank de ist über drei meter
lang ich habe auch meinen alten teile
schrank mitgenommen fürs schlafzimmer
und der ist nicht so hoch aber ich hab
mir das knie ins büro ein
um gottes willen das ist kein ankreidet
zimmer ich bin nicht der typ von krebs
immer ich bin ich bin relativ sparsam
dass die klamotten angeht das ist eher
so dass man da auch mal die lichter
verstauen kann in staubsauger dass man
einfach nicht alles herum fliegen hat
genau das ist für heute die aufgabe ja
das ist die aktuelle situation bewahrten
jetzt auch den internetanbieter das
telefon geht und dann macht haben sie
ins internet
was soll das also kinoatmosphäre das
war's mit sauberen schuhen hatte die
extra in die waschmaschine geschickt die
man so blitzblank und deshalb ist beim
umzug angehabt sehr schlau
einige stunden später der schrank ist
drin die einzelteile die werden
demnächst erst aufgebaut kommt noch so
ein paar kleine arbeiten und dann sind
wir fertig das ist eure fragen also das
hat mein verbraucher gerade gemacht wir
wollten die mich unbedingt so ein
wasserfall wasserhahn wasserfall wasser
haben sagt man das so wollten es
unbedingt mal haben
fertig oh okay wenn ich daran denke wie
verwachsen weil ich weiß ganz viele
fragen und bestimmter ganzen welt
inspirieren
ein neuer tag wir haben es heute sonntag
gestern haben es nicht mehr viel
passiert deshalb habe ich nicht mehr
mitgenommen aber heute wirds spannend
heute treffen wir uns mit der torten
frau mit der parie und besprechen unsere
hochzeitstorte endlich passiert mal was
in richtung hochzeitsvorbereitung und
ich bringen der parie selbst gemachte
pralinen mit in so einem kleinen süßen
schachtel und die pralinen sind
unterschiedlich gefüllt die weißen sind
mit weißer schokolade und tonga zucker
die hier die in der mitte die schmecken
richtig gut die müsste ich eigentlich
mal abfüllen das schmeckt wie ein braun
die zutaten sind aber keine braune
zutaten also richtig interessant und die
anderen sind einfach nur mit zart bitter
so richtig schöne zeit bei der
schokolade gefüllt
[Musik]
dass man beim klassiker muss auch dabei
sein wenn die 30 so unsicher sind
da sage ich da könnt ihr auch wenn ich
am meisten genommen am meisten wird in
bergen namen so schmeckt vorwahlen das
kann ich mir auch vorstellen mag dann
gewinnt das sagen ich hoffe das ist ein
klassiker
[Musik]
ich bin wenn ich weiß nicht ob sie echt
sind gerade hier bei der verkostung der
torte und die torte die lasse ich beide
die party machen und schwester von paris
ist auch die partie
und das ist eine ganz witzige geschichte
wir haben uns letztes jahr genau an
diesem ort kennengelernt
also wir haben uns genau angst um 12
2017 hier im roten in essen kennt auch
noch zeit von und sein freund und da hat
die paare die torte gemacht weißt du
noch was ist eine war das waren 16 etage
gezogen
rosen
ich weiß nur noch wie geil die
geschmeckt hat wir haben gesagt ab
diesem datum als ich sie kennengelernt
habe ich gesagt meine torte machst du
bitte und city million verkauften unsere
torte dass deine mindestens genauso
schön wird es auch dann schmeckt auf
jeden fall also falls jetzt neugierig
seid lee die torten von der party
aussehen ich werde euch den link in der
infobox schreiben mache ich auf was
gefasst es ist so pompös und es schmeckt
so gut ich habe dem du weißt hier das
mango paris aktuell besten nachrichten
sollten das sind dass das mango
übernehme schoko erdbeer himbeer kirsch
und einer leckerei als der andere welche
habt ihr euch gehts gewählt welche
sorten also ich stehe total auf schoko
oder ist nämlich auch was drin haben sie
welche fahne doch war der hammer lecker
und himbeer ist auch richtig gut aber
ich will alles nehmen muss man alles gut
also einmal alle bitte wenn wir alle mit
den saiten gespannt die tat mit mega
werden
also es geht heute nicht nur um die
verköstigung der torte sondern ich hab
ja auch die liebe kathi mir und sie wird
unsere fotos machen erzählt auch gern
mal ein bisschen was über dicht mache
die fotos von kiki und haben sich freue
mich schon riesig darauf und von anfang
an dass sich deren fotos machen möchte
schon jetzt dass die fotos wirklich toll
aus
werden weil sie sind beide so süß und so
authentisch und sympathisch einfach und
ich freue mich schon riesig darauf wir
freuen uns auch richtig gut wie am
gleitschirm gesprochen wir haben
riesenpark angrenzend an der wohnung von
meinen eltern und da gehen wir dann auf
jeden fall aufklären da bist du platt
schon sehr gespannt
also ich werde euch den instagram
account auch gerne hier in die infobox
verlinken und dann schreibt sie gerne
mal an da kann man ja gerne wariner
rechtschreiben hier haben so was machst
du da jetzt echt jetzt haben wir alles
besprochen und das beste ist und die
taten so lecker ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen sie du glaub ich auch ich kenne
ich kenne ehrlich gesagt hochzeitstorte
so dass die buttercreme lass dich sind
schwere keiner erwartet wirklich auch
die tote am ende dort sind da ist mir
nicht so interessiert aber ich sage euch
die schmecken wir sind ja auch
hausgemacht die schmecken so gut ist
mein favorit ist wie schoko und
himbeeren manko war auch super lecker
das verdient meint workers lässigkeit
ist hier die übersicht ist aber ich fand
die klassischen hammer eine linke
geschichte
die künstlichen richtig man merkt
einfach dass sie wirklich das sage ich
jetzt auch nicht nur als werbung sein
soll
ich habe die so ins herz geschlossen
schon letztes jahr auf der hochzeit man
merkt dass die hochwertige zutaten
verwendet sondern euro für die paare
kennen gelernt genau und die mutter habe
ich mich gefreut dass die karte die
schwester von dem paar das so gut kann
und wir sind in guten händen und wir
gehen jetzt auch was essen sorgen soll
jetzt für erstmals gegessen
zwar sind wir hier in essen rüttenscheid
vergleichen
ich habe mich kritische üben da erst mal
schön burger gegessen ich liebe bürger
wer liebt auch bürger haben ein rezept
noch hamburger rezept
[Musik]
normalerweise zu chillen und ich krank
waren
150 jahren gebaut worden
[Musik]
überzeugt
so der blog ist hiermit zu ende wir
haben gerade gegessen werden auto haben
so fried wie immer für die frostbeule
thomas euch der rock gefallen hat
schreibt noch gerne in die kommentare
was ihr gerne noch sehen möchtet was
dich interessiert viele haben gesagt
hochzeitsvorbereitungen ich kann euch
diesen standpunkt sagen werden den saal
termin dementsprechend wir haben die
bühnendeko da werde ich euch auch noch
die informationen geben wofür das machen
das mache ich weiß es ganz viele auf der
suche sind nach bündig morgen gesund
wird und auch so ein bisschen
hintergrundwissen
ich gebe dir vollkommen recht so ein
bisschen hintergrundwissen weil ich
kenne das aus meinen kreisen in der
türkei kennt man das gar nicht dass man
ein extra bühnendeko anbieter genau so
ist es eigentlich so wie das heutige
balkan ressourcen das ist bei den
marokkanern gang und gebe mir
mittlerweile ist das so hin
also ich werde euch alles im nächsten
blog ein bisschen berichten wenn euch
das interessiert also schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare
für den nächsten block über was sich um
durch klatschen soll was sie sehen
möchte und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr
jetzt zu einem regulären rezept
einschaltet jeden mittwoch und jeden
sonntag um punkt 10 uhr
bis dahin tschüss